quand on a commencé il y avait deux
chaînes
aujourd'hui on a des dizaines quand on a
commencé il y avait trois radios qu'il
comptait maintenant il y en a des
centaines
donc rien ne peut plus être dissimulé
pas parce que les politiques sont plus
vertueux pas parce que les journalistes
sont plus malades mais parce que la
concurrence l'a imposé
pour les journalistes il ya deux
manières de ne pas remettre en cause le
pouvoir qu'exerce les propriétaires des
médias peuvent le nier tout simplement
ou bien affirmer qu'il est normal voire
naturel que ce pouvoir s'exerce c'est
pas trop douloureux docteur non ça va
c'est un peu comme si dans une famille
certains avaient décidé de faire
politique et votre fair economy et les
troisièmes journaliste s'est installé
dans le monde
c'est un moment unique ça ça me parait
antique heures antilles pour nine
soviétique
la crise financière et a priori passé et
l'économie mondiale est plutôt bien géré
une constance dans l'erreur qui est
accompagné d'une constance filaire dans
l'indigence
il ya des vrais pouvoirs le brésil au
stade pour le capitole il y a un
problème républicain
dès l'instant que de très gros intérêts
financiers sont liées à de très gros
intérêts médiatiques et sont en liaison
intime avec l'état ce sont donc ces
chefferies éditoriale des gardiens
parfaitement lisible l'offre sociale
existe le système jette projet puisqu'il
ne peut pas récupérer
ne restez jamais à l'antenne impunément
notamment lorsque ces puissants et que
danic détiennent de très grandes
oh